[Música]
a vida é cheia de desafios e desde que
eu me conheço por gente eu sou movido a
desafios e teve que romper muitas
barreiras muito prazer eu sou o andré
cintra a minha infância foi uma infância
muito tranquila e tem ótimas recordações
da infância eu lembro que sempre na
minha infância estava em cima de um
skate ou em cima de uma bicicleta ou
pulando muro ou subir numa árvore e
sempre minha mãe estava lá atrás
gritando não é que sai daí vai se
machucar cuidado isso é perigoso
então na infância eu sempre tive muita
muita energia e essa quantidade grande
de energia na adolescência acabou se
transformando numa necessidade muito
grande de ter a minha própria
independência então quando eu tinha 16
anos e resolvi procurar meu primeiro
emprego
consegui meu primeiro emprego e desde
aquele momento eu já tinha o objetivo de
ser independente financeiramente e de
conquistar a independência através de um
sonho eo meu sonho era ter uma moto
com 17 anos eu consegui realizar o meu
sonho conseguir comprar a minha moto
isso pra mim naquele momento foi a minha
primeira grande conquista foi a minha
primeira grande vitória e e foi também
uma sensação de liberdade incrível
imaginar o menino de 17 anos poder ter a
sua própria moto ea liberdade de ir e
vir
então aquilo pra mim naquele momento foi
incrível mas um dia voltando pra casa
com essa mesma moto
eu sofri um acidente
eu caí e foi deslizando por uma calçada
e por ironia do destino talvez existe
uma placa
nessa calçada que tinha uma uma placa de
propaganda de um hospital e eu bati
nessa placa e quando fui levantar para
pegar a moto eu vi que tinha perdido um
pedaço da minha perna ea minha perna
estava a uns 10 ou 12 metros de
distância isso um cara pegou minha perna
trouxe até a mim me entregou e eu me
lembro que eu tava sendo resgatado e
olhava pra minha perna e fechava os
olhos e falava isso é um pesadelo é um
pesadelo um pesadelo vai passar vai
passar vai passar e abrir os olhos do
pesadelo não passava e fecharam
novamente os olhos e um pesadelo é um
pesadelo vai passar a abrir os olhos não
passava o pesadelo não passou não era um
pesadelo era a vida real
naquele dia eu fui amputada abaixo do
joelho a minha perna direita e acordei
no dia seguinte amputada acima do joelho
no hospital naquele dia eu perdi uma
perna mas ganhei uma vida nova e eu tive
que fazer uma escolha a partir daquele
momento que ou eu sentava e chorava para
o resto da vida ou eu levantava e
continuava andando caminhando e essa foi
a decisão que resolvi tomar
eu levantei e continuei caminhando e
isso foi muito importante porque mais ou
menos uns três meses depois o universo
entendendo isso conspirou a favor e me
levou para uma super aventura foi
convidado para uma viagem ao nepal
essa viagem é uma viagem para fazer
rafting durante seis dias de corredeiras
nível 5 e 6
e essa viagem mudou completamente minha
mãe 7 porque nessa viagem lá tanto no
nepal do outro lado do mundo
logo após um acidente eu estava lá e
pensei bom se eu estou aqui há três
meses depois do acidente com uma perna
só fazendo corredeiras nível 5 e 6
então eu posso fazer qualquer coisa e aí
começa uma outra parte da trajetória
quando eu voltei pro brasil
eu comecei a criar as minhas próprias
próteses para continuar fazendo os
esportes que eu já fazia para fazer
outros esportes novos
é comecei a criar minhas próprias
próteses para fazer oito board depois
para fazer katz surf
fui desenvolvendo vários tipos de
próteses diferentes pregava peças mandar
o torneiro mecânico arrumar alguma coisa
depois fazia outra nesse meio do caminho
fui perdendo várias pernas no caminho
para evitar na região de cádiz anf
perder perna andando de bike board e
fazia parte do processo porque cada vez
que eu perdi uma perna e se me motivava
a criar uma perna melhor ou mais segura
ou mais rígida ou enfim com uma
mobilidade diferente lembrando que
naquela época as próteses não são o que
são hoje nessa vez foi 97
então assim não existe a prova
específica para fazer esporte não
existia prova específica pra água então
tive que aprender a criar o meu próprio
jeito de fazer prótese
então aos 21 anos a vida me chamou para
um outro desafio talvez um desafio dos
mais difíceis da minha vida meu pai era
um cara incrível uma pessoa realmente
especial um exemplo de homem e quando eu
tinha 21 anos ele foi uma viagem e ele
sofreu um acidente e faleceu
e nesse dia três fatos mudaram
completamente a minha vida o primeiro
fato foi que eu perdi uma pessoa que eu
tanto amava e que ama até hoje uma
pessoa que era minha referência que era
tudo pra mim
segundo fato foi que com 21 anos eu tive
que assumir a cuidar de uma família que
até então nunca tinha criado na época a
minha mãe já não trabalhava mais eu
tinha um irmão que tinha 14 anos ea
minha irmã tinha 11 anos de idade então
com 21 anos geralmente quando um menino
ainda não tá nem preparado para se
sustentar
não tá nem informado ainda a
responsabilidade e me chamou de uma
maneira diferente e eu tive que aprender
o que é colocar dinheiro em casa aos 21
anos
então isso para mim foi bastante
diferente nessa fase eo terceiro fato
foi o fato de que o meu pai na época de
uma empresa
50 por cento de uma empresa eu herdei
esse 50% da empresa e meu pai tinha um
sócio com os outros 50% e esse sócio
quando meu pai morreu ele me pediu uma
procuração com amplos poderes para
dirigir a empresa porque era muito jovem
e essa procuração foi dada pra ele e
assim ele dirigiu empresa durante os
próximos dois anos
e aos 23 anos a vida me chama por um
outro desafio completamente diferente
porque quando tinha a cidade e descobrir
que esse sócio ele tinha montado uma
outra empresa concorrente da nossa com o
nosso dinheiro sem a gente saber então
foi nesse momento que eu tive que
assumir a empresa da família numa
condição bastante difícil uma condição
financeira muito dura
na época nós tínhamos 101 protestos três
pedidos de falência e alguns milhões de
dívida e eu não tinha a mínima idéia do
que era uma empresa me lembro que na
época o advogado chegou pra mim e falou
assim andré
agora você desconta as duplicatas e vai
tocando na empresa e eu virei pra ele
foi assim doutor que a mesma duplicata
ele botou a mão na testa e falou putz
ferrou se esse moleque não sabe que é
uma duplicata como ele vai dirigir uma
empresa mas eu sempre tive vontade
sempre fui curioso e sempre tive muita
vontade de aprender
mas o que eu acho que me salvou mesmo
foi a minha inocência porque nesse
momento eu procurei todos os
fornecedores chamei eles e contem a
verdade pra eles e falei com os
fornecedores eu preciso de três coisas
a primeira coisa que eu preciso é saber
quanto eu devo eu não sei como eu devo
então por favor sejam verdadeiros
a segunda coisa que eu preciso é que eu
vou pagar todo mundo mas eu não posso
pagar juros
então por favor não me cobrem juros ea
terceira coisa que eu preciso que você
me deixem vivo ou seja se vocês me
forneciam uma quantidade enorme de
matéria prima e de embalagem me manda um
pouquinho de cada coisa um pouco desse
50 quilos nessa matéria prima 30 quilos
da outra para que eu possa ficar ficar
vivo e continua a empresa e assim foi
feito
eu me lembro que
um caderninho preto e eu marquei todos
os fornecedores que eu devia naquele
caderninho e eu recebia naquela época
1.500 e 2 mil reais por dia na empresa e
eu depositava os fornecidos pelos
fornecedores cem reais para 1 150 reais
para o outro
duzentos reais para o outro e eu me
lembro que eles no dia seguinte muitas
vezes negavam furiosos e falavam assim
como é que você é muito folgado você me
deve e não sei quantos milhares de reais
e você me manda 150 reais e eu respondia
bom mas a gente não combinou que eu ia
pagar o que eu tenho para hoje e amanhã
pago mais um pouquinho e isso de uma
certa forma criou uma uma empatia não é
uma uma sensibilidade nos fornecedores e
eles começaram a pensar que bom esse
moleque não tem dinheiro mas ele tem boa
vontade e isso de uma certa forma ajudou
muito a empresa a gente foi recuperando
a empresa conseguir pagar todo mundo foi
aprender realmente sobre negócios foi
estudar para entender como funciona uma
empresa a empresa foi sobrevivendo foi
crescendo e hoje é uma empresa que tem
muito mais funcionário está muito bem
sucedida no mercado 15 anos depois é
completamente diferente do que era a
empresa que eu peguei lá atrás e durante
tudo isso é mais um desafio bastante
importante na minha vida a minha mãe era
uma mulher maravilhosa incrível que
tinha uma conexão muito forte com meu
pai eu acho que no momento que meu pai
morreu ela sente um vazio muito grande e
quando eu tinha 26 anos a gente
descobriu que a minha mãe estava com
câncer e poucos dias depois ela veio a
falecer
e mais uma vez eu vi que perdeu uma
perna muito duro mas perdeu as pessoas
que a gente ama é muito mais difícil
e então aos 28 a vida fez uma outra
reviravolta me convidou para outro
desafio
nessa época eu já andava de kart 7 é
muito tempo e eu sempre tive vontade de
fazer snowboard e tinha feito duas
experiências de snowboard e as duas
muito frustrados porque eu tinha ido pra
neve e não tinha conseguido ficar de pé
direito porque não tinha uma prova
específica para fazer snowboard e essas
duas vezes voltei pro brasil
terminada a fazer uma prova específica
para fazer snowboard mas estava na
correria trabalhando muito não conseguir
fazer mas logo depois surgiu a
oportunidade de ir para os estados
unidos
e eu estava nos estados unidos uma
pessoa me falou assim olha tem um cara
que tava na guerra voltou da guerra
voltou imputado e eles no borderô e ele
fez uma prótese específica pelo board
eu estava na califórnia a empresa esse
cara era em utah
eu liguei na empresa uma moça me atendeu
e falou pra mim assim perguntei na
própria fala olha se você quer a prótese
não tem problema você vem pra cá aí está
após uma semana com a gente ea gente põe
à prova o título mais livre para a área
foi assim olha eu não tenho uma semana
volto ao brasil em dois dias
então eu gostaria que você passar seu
cartão de crédito e me mandasse a
própria pelo correio e ela riu e falou
cara você é maluco ninguém compra uma
prova pelo correio mas essa decisão foi
muito importante porque essa decisão
mudou completamente a minha vida ela
mandou a própria pelo correio após
chegou eu voltei para o brasil e depois
disso comecei a fazer snowboard de
verdade
logo depois um tempo depois há o cpb e à
cbn que o comitê de neve estava
procurando um alguém para tentar uma
vaga nos jogos paralímpicos de inverno
então eu fui convidado para fazer uma
prova
eu fui pra essa prova por acaso nessa
prova estava com o braço quebrado a
cabeça tirando a tipóia para ninguém ver
que estava com o braço quebrado fiz a
prova com o braço quebrado depois bater
pode decidir e fui embora
mas essa decisão também foi muito
importante porque ela mudou
completamente a minha vida também porque
eu passei nessa prova aí a cbdn me
convidou para ser atleta
depois eles me enviaram nos estados
unidos para treinar eu entrei nos
campeonatos mundiais
aí sim eu aprendi o que era ser um
atleta de alta performance o atleta de
alta performance ele não trabalha com
segundos
o atleta de alta performance trabalha
com milésimos de segundos a diferença
tem uma medalha de ouro e você ser
desclassificado no snowboard são
milésimos de segundos
então o planejamento que o comitê tinha
de classificar o brasil foi antecipado
em quatro anos
e eu fui primeiro atleta a classificar o
brasil para uma para olimpíadas de
inverno na história e quando cheguei na
olimpíadas eu não tinha a mínima idéia
do que era olimpíadas não tinha idéia da
magnitude que era olimpíadas não tinha
idéia que eu seja assistido por milhares
de pessoas
não tinha idéia que estaria do lado dos
melhores atletas do mundo quer dizer a
minha ficha só caiu realmente quando
estava lá né
só para vocês terem uma idéia a para
olimpíadas de inverno ela é assistida
por mais ou menos 3 bilhões de pessoas
ao redor do planeta então quer dizer
realmente um evento bom magnífico e foi
muito interessante que na entrada da
cerimônia de abertura um pouquinho antes
da entrada
a gente estava esperando para entrar e
eu recebi uma informação que também foi
muito interessante foi muito legal
o presidente da cbdn chegou pra mim e
diz assim olha já que você foi o
primeiro atleta a classificar o brasil
então você vai levar a bandeira você vai
ser o porta-bandeira do brasil na
entrada e esse foi um dos dias mais
emocionantes da minha vida não é levar a
bandeira do brasil poder empunhar até a
honra de carregar a bandeira do brasil
em olimpíadas e acho que isso foi uma
grande vitória para mim
e aqui tem um vídeo sobre as olimpíadas
[Música]
esse foi outro dia também bastante
importante para o título foi o dia da
competição final
e nesse dia que eu carregava algumas
gotas de latas cada um dos ombros
[Música]
estava um pouco nervoso na primeira
descida e se atrapalhou bastante
eu vi os melhores atletas caindo e os
melhores estão caindo porque realmente a
coisa difícil
[Música]
acho que isso fim tem um motivo especial
porque quando eu perdi minha perna e meu
pai ficou muito mal e eu gostaria muito
que ele tivesse aqui para ver tudo isso
porque ele merecia tanto ele quanto
minha mãe tá aqui pra ver
o que aconteceu tantos anos depois é
porque naquele momento estava muito
preocupado que não tivesse uma vida
[Música]
normal boa e agora muitos anos depois
é como os melhores lugares do mundo
[Aplausos]
a vida é uma grande aventura e claro as
aventuras continuam
recentemente nós fizemos um documentário
no canal off chamados hubs enfim um
documentário e um livro 600km de kite
surf sendo puxado pelo vento com uma
prancha no pé
foram sete dias saindo o ceará e indo
até os lençóis maranhenses no maranhão
quer dizer mais uma outra aventura
incrível e o meu próximo grande desafio
é conseguir classificar o brasil para os
próximos jogos paralímpicos de inverno
na coréia do sul ano que vem
[Música]
e naquele dia que eu sofri o acidente
alguém tivesse me dito que um dia eu ia
ser um atleta de alta performance e o
dia eu ia pro olimpíadas que um dia ia
carregar a bandeira do brasil
eu nunca teria acreditado
então acredito em si mesmos nós somos
muito mais forte muito mais poderosos do
que a gente imagina
a mente manda o corpo obedece
muito obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]